hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear ok I'm back at
the park and listen to the lady she's so
fine you get to see me like that I'm so
alright I'm not gonna die because I
actually have to what day where are you
going buddy all right those crazies kind
of easier and less scary when they're
alright what do I know it's got crosses
of blood on it I should check it out ok
I am here they're there they're all over
the place
whatever no don't shoot it
what are you doing shooting it alright
umm I'm trying to find a reference I'm
trying to look at this thing
what is that I don't know okay whatever
it's just up there maybe
here
anything can't see
well I don't see anything
something here I should try and dig it
okay dig loser
oh there's alright let's see maybe I yup
British humble pride burner stick drop
it it's a shovel kidding me are whatever
whatever whatever whatever
here here their dicks so big that
ass-backwards
oh it's just items so that one was there
just down here come on show me gentleman
to mana here are there
[Music]
give me the goodies Oh rifle rounds here
here no the ground looks thank you diggy
diggy like cable keep digging I don't
have an m16 hmm all right there
farther down okay there are two there
let's like this - there
like there's a big container on top of
it don't know how that got there but
anyway alright there's one up here just
right here yeah just to the right and
then up beyond right here here here here
here here here there it is
bingo gimme I'm guessing this is like a
completely optional but it always pays
to start
when you know you're not
shut up wind where are they
darn it where is it I saw it on the
bathrooms up here like that the hack
right there up here it should be right
here but it's not it's not right there
it's not all right okay just over
Oh suck it up run a lap and your size
shape that looks like it
we're not back there it is this will be
the last there we go look at some fool
it's a tall old
mark
did I not need to come into the park at
all something is blocking the door
that's helpful mom whatever I'm out of
here
I guess I did there's a line of cars
that I can't jump over here I'm a big
swim doors unlock I guess from here
maybe Oh go I have to dig for a key
kidding me right
Bologna where's that last one the one
that was on the map it was supposed to
be up here but I can't find it like it's
behind that thing
I'm taking one
oh okay to breathe hair okay yeah that
line is the wall okay this is the wall
there's something there was that era
where oh maybe I should check that out
there's another area there okay another
door ah come on if there's something
else don't hide it from me I'll make me
go through this
baloney ah whereby all did I I've lost
and now my baton is gone huh
okay did I get that one did I I think I
did I got that one I definitely got this
one this one and this one and that one
yeah and let me shovel check for that
one pretty yeah I did okay I got all of
them what do you want from me what do I
have to do oh use a shovel on it blow
the lock with your pistol
well I'm lost too bound to happen for
them laws videos gentlemen
oh don't get so tired maybe I didn't oh
wait oh okay
okay I can go around here and um right
here yes please be a key or something
okay yes
inventory Oh bull hockey no oh what
watch awesome bucket
you want some shotgun whatever you is
whatever you is you ain't scary who's
out there
ah oh it's bed man
hey I got I got some special medicine
for you
secure your chronic insomnia what what
what what hang on I'm almost got it
there we go what what what what what
right on yeah these these monsters make
sense what I came to see my crosshair
bullets lovely I'm sorry I brought gonna
just run past him
why did I bother it's not like they can
hit me that well whatever unlocked it
let me in I gotta go meet some lady on
the roof oh yeah no lady can resist the
roof crying or laughing sounds like
crying
it's a deaf baby oh look at sad huh
who's out there
aha gotcha who's in here huh
what done Oh Monty be that Downers look
feel steaming mug save
these save coins are getting farther and
farther
huh oh yes I can
that seems smart
look at that view it's so Purdy ah what
hook no oh oh no you didn't woge um
perfectly cool I made it I didn't die
which is like a first here aerial items
if only I had a machine gun lonely I
will make this stupid epic leap and then
die oh what's that oh you look so sad
down there hey hold still I wanna talk
to you hey hey hey hey wait bullets do
the talking oh yeah yep
dad just like that alright
another guy don't even here goes please
yeah I don't know that you're closing
down save that innovation screw you I'm
just going on you're not scary
you're not even be dangerous Oh was that
you're spitting blood at me all right I
gotta cut it here thank you guys so much
for watching as always I will see you in
the next one markiplier out